[Music]
hey guys Natalie here and welcome back
to hey it's a good life so today is
Friday happy Friday
that means that it's vlog day so today I
am taking you guys along with us as we
do all of our chores here on the urban
homestead and yeah I think it's going to
be a great day on the homestead so
without further ado let's hop into
things on today's agenda I will be doing
my exercises first and foremost a lot of
you guys know I sustained a really
serious injury about two years ago and
I'm finally just now getting into a
really good groove of healing and that
means that I have to stay up on my
exercises every single day burns it's
crazy to think like this is hard for me
right now when I used to play college
volleyball but I'm coming to terms with
the fact that I have a back injury and
it's gonna take a long time to get
better in fact it's gonna be the journey
of a thousand steps like so many good
things in life but it also feels really
good
[Music]
all right I've got my worms you ready to
go I try not to make this thing too
heavy because our back injury if you
guys want to know how to make your own
warranty I've got a link just click
right there
[Music]
while your feed my plants with warm tea
in the morning because that is when the
pores of the plant are most open like
think of plants right there ready to
accept that morning dew first thing in
the morning over the course of the day
they kind of closed those pores that
night they open them back up and then
they kind of closed as the day goes on
so in the morning is one of the best
times to feed plants because their pores
are more open but also it's not as hot
especially in the summer you want to be
mindful of when you boil your few plants
because you don't want to burn them but
one great thing about warm tea is that
the likelihood in general of burning
your plants is very low because it is a
very balanced very gentle fertilizer and
so I'm never really worried that I'm
gonna burn my plants but I do try to be
mindful of that I take care of them in
the morning rather than in the noonday
Sun or even at night because because the
likelihood of them absorbing as many of
the nutrients as possible it's just so
much a lower at night than it is in the
morning I love this plant so much and I
did not save the tag I did not write it
down and I cannot remember the name to
save so anyway I do you know it leave it
in a comment down below please
[Music]
there we go
I got stuck I gotta help my tomcat out
he might be a little camera-shy but I
love him and he's my Tomcat okay at that
time we are gonna build the garden beds
and hopefully we're gonna get this
knocked out in just a couple hours today
Tommy is helping me because I'm still
getting over this back injury and it's
important to ask for help and not
believe that you're superwoman so today
he's gonna be helping me and I'm super
excited to have his help it's always
nice to have a buddy and build things
together and together we are gonna show
you how to build some really simple
really easy bag friendly rent friendly
garden beds I'm so excited I cannot wait
to see how they turn out all right my
friends let's talk about this plan here
is what you're gonna need for this
project then we are going to put this
all together by sanding cutting you can
see my shownotes cut list down below and
putting it all together
I want to share with you guys
our supplies because I want to encourage
you guys to get creative you guys might
have stuff laying around your property
that you can use just like us we are
actually repurposing these cedar fence
pickets which were laying in the back of
our property just unused for years and
they have this really beautiful finish
that I'm about to show you I love how we
can take something that was old and
forgotten about and restore life to it
by standing it down and giving it this
new kind of like rustic patina look I
just love the way it's finished and I
want us to share that with you guys
because I think it's really easy to feel
like we have to use all new products
another thing to consider to save money
on this project is using coal lumber
which is lumber that has been damaged
and thus discounted this piece of wood
had a crack on one end of it for about
foot and a half and so what I was able
to do is just cut that part off and then
use the rest of this beautiful wood for
the project
[Music]
another money saving tip is buying
lumber that is extraordinarily long this
is a 16 foot 2x4 and I bought this when
I built our raised garden beds about a
year ago and it helped me save a
significant amount of money per garden
bed so it was a decent amount of savings
and well worth the extra trouble and
here Tommy is helping me set up a stop
block which helps you to quickly and
easily cut the same sized pieces of wood
very quickly very easily and I'll show
you what that looks like in just a
second because essentially you just butt
up the wood to the stop block to the
length that you need it to be and then
you cut from there so this is what that
looks like
[Music]
once we had all of our wood cut and
sanded it was time to lay everything out
I'm a really visual person so I like to
lay the project out to make sure that I
cut everything that I need and so laying
everything out in this way helps me see
that and I thought I would share that
process with you guys and keep that's
helpful to any other fellow visual
learners
[Music]
all right the moment we've all been
waiting for the actual build of this
project is so easy it does help to have
somebody there with you to just kind of
keep the boards in place I've done it by
myself though so it's fully possible to
do it on your own however it was really
nice to have a buddy and so if you have
somebody who can help you a neighbor a
friend a spouse a partner I definitely
recommend that now this is one of my
favorite parts I don't know that I've
talked a lot about this on my channel
but these I believe are called cornered
clamps and it helps me build boxes
really really easily especially if I'm
building by myself and I really like
these because it does help you get a
really nice clean 90 degree angle I've
built boxes and out using corner clamps
before and I don't think that they
turned out as well so we use these
corner clamps to really square
everything up and then once everything
is in those corner claims you basically
have a box and you just have to screw it
together once you've got your box it's
time to lay these in there I'm not
really sure what to call these Tommy
called these spanners and then you'd
fight your garden bed all that's left to
do is lay down the slats
[Music]
and here is the final product pre-stain
some of these boards are stained because
we repurposed them from an old project
but I actually really liked this kind of
like combination of wood colors I don't
know why but let me know in the comments
down below if you guys think I should
finish staining or leave as is now once
you've got the slats in these beds all
you have to do is fill them with pots
and that is why I think this is such a
genius rent friendly solution because
you could repurpose seasonal pots like
this one or you can use dollar store
pots like this one just make sure
whatever it is it's got great drainage
that's why I'm kind of plucking out some
of the plastic here to make sure that
there are good drainage holes because
that's really important for healthy
plants and you can also use grow bags
and that is what I am using the majority
of to fill these beds with these are
three gallon grow bags that I got on
Amazon and I'll include a link in the
show notes down below once these are all
filled I basically have a very
straightforward very portable brent
friendly square foot garden and I
actually wish I had thought of this
sooner because I think it would have
saved me a lot of shoveling dirt into
our garden beds but alas my failures can
be your successes and I'm really happy
to share this with you guys here is the
final result pre planting and I really
love how it looks
thanks so much for joining me today you
guys I hope you enjoyed this video and
if you did please be sure to give it a
thumbs up subscribe and hit the bell as
well I'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]